So next up, let's go on to exercise three, and in this we're going to be looking at
using the post process material. So as you can see here, I have a little scene in front of us
where we have some random shapes. And what we're going to be doing here is we're going
to be using the post process in order to create an outline effect with these.
So what we're going to be using is the custom depth buffer. So let's have a look at this to
start with. We have a post process volume, and for this we have the post process material,
as you can see down in the details panel, and we have one assigned, and that's the one
that we have here. But at the moment it's doing nothing. And let's have a look why.
So if I open this up, and kill this down, see that we have nothing plugged into our
post process material. Even more importantly, our material domain is incorrect. We have this
in surface. So we do a drop down, change this to post process, and apply. You're going to see
that the world goes black. And that's because this post process material is taking over
the screen. If I move outside of the post process volume, you can see that it's no longer in
action. I can always make the post process volume have an infinite extent by taking unbound,
tick this button here. That means that anywhere it would apply. But for simplicity, we just
want to be able to jump out of it. Okay, so let's jump into our post process material.
And one of the most important nodes that you'd ever want to use within a post process material
is Scene Textures. So if I was to right-hand-click and click in Scene,
Texture, let's put it correctly, you'll see that I get a node that looks like this. If I
was to plug this into the emissive color, it's going to give us an error. And that's because
the default material domain is Surface, and we're working in post process. So the Surface domain
is not available to us. However, with this selected, you'll see that we have a drop down
box in the left hand corner here. And this is going to give us access to a whole load of
different, well, buffers really. And these are going to be things such as, for example,
we have the world normals, the metallic buffer, the specular. So if I was to select world normals,
for example, you can see that we get different values depending on the direction the normals
are looking in. To apply, you can now see that that applies it to the world here where
blue is directly up. Now these buffers, you can actually have a look at if you
jump into buffer visualization. You'll see that we have a lot of the buffers here,
so that we've got things such as like metallic, and the post process seems to be overpowering
that. But these are similar to what we will be able to grab within here, because these are
the G buffers. So as you are calculating the screen, the Unreal is going away and it's
taking each of the different meshes and effects and stuff like that, and it's breaking them down
into individual render buckets. And then afterwards it will compile them all together into a G buffer,
which is a texture the size of your screen, which it will use then in order to generate
the final image. So these are all of the different G buffers. We have diffuse color,
scene color for example, which is just plain color, scene depth, or scene color, diffuse color.
You can see we've got a load of different elements here. Now we are going to be working
with, so the first thing is we want the original scene back here. We need to use that,
and we can get that by selecting the post process input zero. So you'll see once we've selected
that, we're back to normal. We jump in the level, the level looks like it's normal,
but this will allow us to do an overlay or do sort of different creations.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to hold down the L key, left click into the material
chart, and I'm going to plug this alert into the output pen, and I'm going to plug our post
process into the A. We've touched on lerps before. If the alpha is zero, it will show what's
picked in A. If the alpha is one, it will show what's in B. And anything in between,
it will give us different values. Now I'm going to duplicate this scene texture by pressing
CTRL D. And in order for us to create this outline, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
use something that's called scene depth. Now, if you search for depth, you see that we've
got scene depth here. If I was to plug that directly in, we would get pure white.
And that's because the input for a material is looking for values between zero and one.
But what scene depth is returning is it's returning the depth of the pixel
based on in centimeters away from the camera. So in order to get any kind of value that we can
see, I'm going to need to divide this. So let's say I divide this by, I don't know, let's say
four thousand and now apply. You can have a look in the scene. You can see that we now have
the scene depth. This is going to tell us how far away a specific actor is in centimeters
divided by a thousand. So things that are black are going to be close by. Things that are white
are going to be far away. And that's useful for us. Now it's not actually scene depth that
we want to use. What we want to use is something that's called custom depth. And this
runs in exactly the same way as the scene depth. So if I still apply it through four thousand,
we can see that. But now we only see one of these cones and one of these spheres.
So why is that? That's because the cone and the sphere, I have ticked on the box
for custom depth. So you can see here we have custom depth. So what this will do
is as soon as I mark it as rendered in the custom depth, rendering custom depth pass here,
what it's going to do is there is a secondary depth pass. So the first depth pass we showed
showed the entire scene. The secondary depth pass, the custom depth, will only show any of
the elements that have this box ticked. So this allows us to tick these and show them within
this pass. So if we jump back into the material, what we can do is I'm going to
let's add some extra code in. I'm going to take the color, do a divide, but this time by
fifty thousand. Then I'm going to do a one minus. So this just swaps it over. So
rather from black to one, we white, we are swapping them over. And then I will do a
clap. I'm going to clamp this value only to point nine. I'm going to plug that into the alpha
and into the second pin here. I'm just going to plug a color. So I'm going to push four
and I'm going to go to blue, make sure the alpha is one, and plug that into the
lower. Now, because it's only point nine, it will never be completely blue.
It will always be at least 10 percent the post process texture. Now if I go save and apply,
you can see that these are outlined. Now one of the things you might notice is it jitters
a little bit. Now we can fix that by in the post process volume, we can change the blendable
location. So if I was to search here, we just change it to, I usually find that
seeing color after depth of field will calm it down a bit. Then that looks a lot better.
So you can now see we've created a way of drawing an x-ray around these different items.
Now that's a good demonstration. It's a good basic way of putting stuff together. However,
we can get a lot more advanced for this. Let's jump on to the next version here.
You can see that we have an effect with the scrolling B. Now these scrolling stripes.
Now this is really, really useful in order to highlight an object. It is good for a UI
within the world. You can see here we've got a couple of other abilities as well.
We're using the depth field so that if there's something in the way, it doesn't do the x-ray
effect so that we can just create this highlighting effect. I think if I come into
the world here and just run up to this here, you should see that the character now has it.
Because all I've done, and so now the character is fully displayed on this.
In order to create this effect, it's quite simple. You can see that we have this model here.
If I was to open this up, what I've done is when the third person character gets close to it,
I will set the rendered custom depth value to true. It allows me to just turn that rendered
depth pass on to true and then I can dictate within the post process volume how that would
be calculated. So that programmatically you can do at runtime and that's just by changing the
flicking this box, this value on if a mesh or skeletal mesh is rendered in the custom depth
house.